يمسك القلم وباخرى يحمل طفله هكذا ظهر
الاستاذ الجامعي السوداني اشرف ابراهيم
ادم بصوره اذهلت السودانيين بعد تداولها
على مواقع التواصل
الاستاذ الجامعي جذب الانظار بمشهد غير
مالوف قبل بالاعجاب والثناء ليعتبره
المتفاعلون رمزا للتفاني والتضحيه وشهد
هذا الاستاذ على مدار اسبوع كامل وهو يدرس
طلابه حاملا صغيره فوق كتفه طوال المحاضره
حسب ما ذكرت صفحه جمعيه
طلاب كليه الهندسه في السودان طبعا
الدكتور اشرف ادم هو احد محاضري قسم
الهندسه الكهربائيه في جامعه كاليري
بالخرطوم سيكون اليوم ضيفنا في صباح
العربيه ليحكي لنا القصه كامله
ومن عبر الهاتف ينضم الينا الاستاذ
الجامعي اشرف ابراهيم استاذ اشرف هل
تسمعني
السلام عليكم السلام عليكم استاذ اشرف كيف
صحتك
جايه
هذه الصوره اللي كنا تفاعلنا معها يعني مش
بس الجمهور في السودان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام عليكم يا احمد
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
الناس بتتخيلوا زي ما بتحسن الظروف لبعض
الناس
دائري
[موسيقى]
يعني
عادي جدا
نعم استاذ اشرف يعني شو ممكن تحكي لنا عن
التعاطف الكبير الذي تلقيته او تلقته هذه
الصوره صورتك وانت تحمل ابنك
والله
والذي نفسه بغير جمال لا يرى في الوجود
يعني جميله الناس نفوز الجميله بيشوفوا ان
المساله دي جميله
والناس نفسه
بين الفرصه دي وبقول كل الطلاب في
الجامعات التصوير في الجامعه ما ما ما
مطلوب مع محبه لانه انت المفروض تركز في
محاضرتك وحتى لو صورتها الصوره بها
احتفاظا بخصوصيه الناتج وخصوصيه الاخرين
خليها عندك ما تحاول تنشر بس ويمكن بالعكس
كان يعني فخور بيك او لانه هذا الشيء يعني
جميل انك تحاول تنظم بين العمل
وايضا البيت او المنزل
[موسيقى]
بين
الشعور اللي بيقود لتعاقد الجميع مثلا او
ما تكون معاك في نفس الموضوع لكن
انت عندك نعم استاذ اشرف يعني هل التقيت
هذا الطالب الذي التقط هذه الصوره وكيف
كان اذا التقيته طبعا كيف كان اللقاء هل
كان ايجابيا ام سلميا هل التقطت هذا
الطالب ام شكرته على هذه الخطوه التي قام
بها
لا لا لا لا انا نهائي ما كنت على الطالب
ده لانه هو ده اكبر عن الشيء اللي حس به
فده احساس وانا بشكره عليه وخالص لكن
الاحتفاظ بالخصوصيه ضربه مهمه لكن انا
صحيح
وبيحاول يعكسها لكن يكون في مراعاه شويه
كذا
للخصوصي الاستاذ الجامعي اشرف ابراهيم ادم
شكرا على هذا اللقاء الهاتفي معنا في صباح
العربيه